hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host John
Carroll and today it is back to quantum
mechanics one of our favorite topics
here it is going to continue to be a
favorite topic this calendar year since
of course I have a book on quantum
mechanics coming out September 10th
something deeply hidden quantum worlds
and the emergence of space-time
so I'm scattering a few episodes about
quantum mechanics throughout the year
we've already had the discussion with
David Albert the philosopher of physics
at Columbia where David talked about his
objections to the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
which is my favorite way of thinking
about quantum theory and today I'm gonna
give you the pro many-worlds point of
view but we're doing it in an
interesting way today is a flipped
podcast it's not a solo podcast with
just me talking but I'm also not the
interviewer Rob Reed who is a podcaster
himself is interviewing me and this is
going to be an episode of Rob's podcast
after on so Rob is an entrepreneur and
an author he's the author of several
books including a couple of novels one
of the novels is called after on and his
podcast goes by the same name now
ordinarily if someone else has me on as
a guest on their podcast I would not
qualify that as an episode of mindscape
maybe sometimes I will do that but it'll
be very rare the special circumstances
here are that Rob and I really worked to
shape the course of the discussion ahead
of time so that it really would give me
an opportunity to talk about the
motivation and themes in my upcoming
book something deeply hidden so it's my
pitch
guided by Rob's questions as sort of
someone who's not an expert in quantum
mechanics so hopefully I do not get too
esoteric for people to know what's going
on
so I try to give the basic picture of
why you should be interested in many
worlds what many world says etc it's
just a little taste there's many more
things to be said but hopefully it'll be
comprehensible I do encourage everyone
to take a listen to Rob's podcast after
on he recommended three different
episodes that mindscape listeners might
like to hear one is episode 21 with Mary
Lou Jepsen who is a serial entrepreneur
and is trying to revolutionize medical
imaging
episode 6 of after on is with Sam Harris
and Sam and Rob talked about his novel
after on and the themes of the novel a
little Silicon Valley also a little bit
about terrorism lone-wolf terrorism
which appears in the book and then
episode 40 of after on is with avi Loeb
an astronomy professor at Harvard and
avi is an influential astronomer but
what they talk about is his ideas about
OH mamama I think I'm pronouncing that
correctly actually I'm pretty sure I'm
not pronouncing that correctly but there
was this visitor from outer space that
flew through the solar system from
interstellar space and avi examined the
possibility that it could be an alien
starship that was doing the weird things
that Obama was noticed to do it's very
unlikely that that's right and I think
that all these honest about that but it
makes for a fascinating scientific
discussion so we have a fascinating
scientific discussion today I'll try to
make everyone a convert to my favorite
version of quantum mechanics or at least
to convince you the quantum mechanics is
something everyone should really care
about so let's go
[Music]
so Shawn thanks so much for having me
over to your office this is actually my
very first time visiting Caltech so I'm
really glad that we were able to meet
here before we dive into the spectral
world of quantum mechanics I thought it
would be interesting if you could give
us a quick survey of the two nodes of
your professional career it's almost as
if your career is in a state of
superposition it's almost like that you
know one thing I do you know the day job
what pays the bills is I'm a research
theoretical physicist here at Caltech
which means I sit in my office or at
Starbucks or wherever with pencil and
paper or these days with iPad pro and
Apple pencil and scribble equations and
I'm trying to figure out the laws of
physics roughly speaking grandly
speaking I suppose
so traditionally I've done a lot of work
in cosmology field theory gravitations
of things like what happened at the
beginning of the universe what's the
universe made of dark matter dark energy
things like that these days it's more in
foundations of physics so foundations of
quantum mechanics for one thing we'll be
talking about today but also statistical
mechanics so that's my research right
papers put them in journals have
graduate students the whole bit and then
when I'm not doing that I have an active
program that is more outward facing so
part of that is writing things like
textbooks but part of it is writing
things like trade books so books that
I've written so far on the Higgs boson
the arrow of time the big picture and
now quantum mechanics yes so upcoming in
September that's right September 10 it's
called something deeply hidden the
subtitle is quantum worlds and the
emergence of space-time so something
deeply hidden is a quote from Einstein
when he was a kid
young Einstein is given a compass and he
holds it in his hand and moves it around
and the needle always points to the
north and in his own retelling this is
what got him interested in science he
said there must be something deeply
hidden going on that explains this weird
phenomenon and he stuck with that
attitude for his whole life that we
don't simply in science accept results
we want to understand what's going on
and that turns out to be very
relevant for our current to conversation
about quantum mechanics and let's not
leave out that you're a fellow podcaster
I'm also a podcaster that's right the
mindscape podcast yeah I've been doing
this for a little bit less than a year
now and having a great time and I looked
online last night I am two episodes
ahead of you which means that you will
pass me within the month because I only
do a couple episodes a month and you
keep up a very relentless week-in
week-out you had five episodes in April
but I would say anybody who enjoys
either of these podcasts would enjoy the
other and you do a great deal of science
but you range very broadly as well you
had a wine genius on just a couple of
weeks ago yeah that's part of the joy
for me when I was writing my book the
big picture because of the broad scope
of that book there was neuroscience and
philosophy and evolutionary biology
involved so I got to knock on people's
doors and interview them right
Jack Shostak who's a Nobel prize-winning
biologist I could call him up and say
hey can I come visit and chat for a
couple hours I'm writing a book and when
the book was done that ability went away
I no longer had the license to do that
but now I have a podcast and I can do
that yeah I have a similar background in
that many years ago I wrote a book about
the rise of the Internet as a commercial
medium as it was happening 1996 I was
writing it and that was pure license to
talk to anybody and I interviewed over
probably 200 people for that book Wow
and then that license vanished for
decades right and then I started doing
the podcast and I was like oh wow I get
to do that again yes this is really
really cool so of course today we're
gonna be talking about quantum mechanics
above all the many-worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics which you subscribe
to and is a fascinating one in terms of
its ramifications particularly for me as
a science fiction writer I'll add and
I'll just frame things by saying my own
fascination with quantum mechanics began
when I first entered the tech industry
I'd studied Arabic and Middle Eastern
history in college so I didn't have a
traditional Silicon Valley background to
say the least and I quickly discovered
that essentially every tech product in
the world is enabled by quantum
mechanics in that every single
semiconductor starting with the very
first transistor in 1947 has been
designed around extremely well modeled
quantum behaviors and profoundly
reliable quantum equations
and given how ubiquitous technology is I
think it's fair to say that probably
most of what separates life today from
life in 1947 sits atop this foundation
of a partial mastery that we currently
have of quantum mechanics and what was
bizarre about that to me was two things
first of all I found the entire quantum
realm to be so bizarre and essentially
impossible to understand and even hard
to believe in as I'd over and deeper
into it and the other thing was that
very few if any of my colleagues in
Silicon Valley knew any more about this
stuff than I did if you weren't involved
in designing semiconductors it didn't
really enjoy your life but given that
this entire edifice trillions of dollars
in value basically modern society and
the bigger picture tens if not hundreds
of millions of lives saved or extended
byproducts that sit on top of this
anyway
the contribution of quantum mechanics to
modern society is impossible to
overstate but I would imagine you might
argue that all that is eclipsed by the
contribution it is made to science and
to our understanding of reality is that
true I would argue that quantum
mechanics is important because it's
right as far as we know it is the way
nature works there's zero evidence ever
done by an experimental physicist to say
well maybe there's a flaw in quantum
mechanics maybe we need to do better so
two peculiar things despite that
starting with the simple fact that we
really don't know how it works well this
is the weird thing and this is the major
motivation for writing a book it's
really embarrassing how physicists have
let quantum mechanics go without being
understood for so long it's the best
theory we have and yet there are these
questions that anyone can ask about it
that modern physicists don't have the
ability to give a consensus answer to
right there's a famous quote from
Richard Feynman saying I think I can
safely say that nobody understands
quantum mechanics and that's
embarrassing and even more embarrassing
is that we don't admit it's an
embarrassment rather than saying look
this is a tremendous issue that we
should devote enormous intellectual
resources to we say ah that's not
important we have other things to do
equally fascinate
as the fact that we don't really
understand what's going on is the
complete nonchalance about that not just
with the people at the local Starbucks
but in the theoretical physics community
something that I didn't realize until I
learned that from you and to me it's
almost like imagine we're so good at
predicting the weather that we know it
full year in advance down to the number
of drops in every storm and we have
these immaculate predictions at the
entire travel industry agricultural
industry wedding industry sits atop but
even if you go to a Nobel prize-winning
weathermen and they probably have no
bells for weatherman if there was this
well understood they'd say I don't know
I think it might be a thunder God and
another weatherman would say well some
people think it's a result of conscious
Minds interacting with clouds and
another person would say sunspots and
you can ask a hundred top weathermen
which one of these things is it and most
of them would be like I just don't
really care that just blows my mind it
should this is the scandal skeleton in
the closet at the heart of modern
physics if all you cared about was
making predictions about the future
we've got quantum mechanics pretty much
suss but you can easily go up to a
physicist and that's cool ok what's
happening when we do this measurement of
a quantum system Thunder gods or sunspot
it's just a black box it's an Oracle
it's not an understanding we can get the
answers out we don't know why and
fascinatingly that's enough for not just
most of the people in normal life but
for most of the people working in
theoretical physics so this is the third
imponderable to me a it's so successful
yet we don't know how it works B most
people in the field don't particularly
care but see there is an outright
hostility to probing that you have a few
good anecdotes in the book of people who
have experiences including yourself with
some of the papers you've written and so
forth
yeah there's story after story of
brilliant physicists who tried very hard
to understand quantum mechanics and
we're either ridiculed or kicked out of
the field there's a famous example where
the editor of the physical review the
major journal in physics sent out a memo
saying don't allow any publications in
the foundations of quantum mechanics
it comes in mild and more virulent forms
I've only felt it relatively mild
literally while I began writing the book
I was also in my other part of our
superposition of what I do for a living
was writing a grant proposal or a group
grant proposal here at Caltech to the
Department of Energy theoretical physics
and I'm writing what I do that's what I
supposed to say and I was told you know
leave out that stuff you do on the
foundations of quantum mechanics not
just like under emphasize it but don't
even mention it it makes you look less
serious and brilliant people john bell
who's in one of the most influential
people in the foundations of quantum
mechanics was a scientist at cern who
also did research in theoretical
particle physics and didn't tell any one
of his colleagues at CERN that he worked
on the foundations of quantum mechanics
so why does that bias exist it's a
really interesting historical
development it goes back to the 1920s
when quantum mechanics was coming into
shape and 1927 there was literally a
single event the fifth Solvay conference
which is the point at which we had
quantum mechanics in its modern mature
form the same quantum mechanics we teach
in textbooks today it really has a
birthday it has a birthday exactly that
was the setting for the famous Einstein
Bohr debates so Albert Einstein of
course Niels Bohr the godfather of
quantum mechanics they were two of the
grand old men at the conference even
though they were both in their late 40s
at the time and they debated about do we
have quantum mechanics is it done yet
they both believed it right and Einstein
in particular gets a very bad rap as
someone who was too old and set in his
ways to really understand quantum
mechanics or be satisfied with it he
understood it better than anybody and
wasn't his Nobel for work that he did
and yeah he helped invent quantum yeah
yeah he invented the photon he mended
the fact that light is quantized that's
kind of a big deal kind of a big deal
but he said look we're not done yet
there are puzzles here that make no
sense and he tried over the years to
sharpen those puzzles into a true
logical inconsistency and never quite
succeeded at that but the other side was
Bohr and his co-workers who said look
it's good enough let's stop talking
about
what really happens let's just use the
Oracle the black box let's do work with
it and if you think about history right
1920s okay what happens soon thereafter
there's World War two and in physics
there's the invention of nuclear physics
radioactivity and soon thereafter
particle physics condensed matter
physics superconductivity it's a really
amazingly fruitful time in the history
of physics largely because quantum
mechanics was invented if you buy a new
sports car you could spend a year
looking at the engine and trying to
understand it or you could take it out
for a spin right so the last 90 years of
quantum mechanics have been taking out
for a spin without really understanding
the engine and that bore Einstein debate
persisted over many many years after the
Solvay conference it did and Bohr never
really understood what Einstein was
saying but he won the PR battle you know
Bohr was an amazingly successful mentor
he had an Institute he had acolytes he
was personally enormous ly charismatic
and charming and his word was spread and
Einstein was kind of a loner didn't
really like to work with people and very
often when he did collaborate with
someone he would stop talking to them
soon thereafter because they did
something that he didn't approve of and
so his word never quite got out there in
the same way and he's in Stein right
like it's not as if he was some little
gadfly who no one had heard of to set
the stage for talking about quantum
physics just a very very brief overview
of Newtonian physics to give us a point
of comparison particularly the
all-encompassing
salience of two simple variables
position and velocity Newton invented
classical mechanics as we now call it in
the 1600s and it was really Peirce among
applause circa 1800 who put his finger
on this fact that if you knew the
position and velocity of everything in
the universe Newtonian mechanics lets
you predict everything that will ever
happen and retro dict everything that
ever did happen in the past it's the
clockwork universe just those two
variables
exactly so you need to know where
everything is where every particle or
every little bit of fluid or whatever it
is and how fast they're moving this is
what we call the state of a physical
system in Newtonian mechanics the
position and the velocity because that's
the info you need
to predict what will happen next and
toward the end of the 19th century
physicists might have been forgiven if
they thought they were getting near the
end zone right because the great depth
of understanding of both particles and
fields what Newton gave us in the 1600s
was a general framework he gave us a
paradigm a way that physics could be you
give me stuff and then you tell me where
it is and how fast it's moving and I
tell you everything else and so the
whole project of physics seemed to be
trying to figure out what was the stuff
of which the universe was made then you
plug into the Newtonian cookbook and
everything follows from that now by the
end of the 1800s it seemed that there
were two kinds of stuff everything is
either a particle or a field matters
made of particles the forces between the
particles are mediated by fields those
seem to be a good general framework for
doing physics and then it was just a
matter of what are the particles what
are the fields and then yeah circa 1900
all comes crashing it all comes crashing
down very very roughly speaking the road
to quantum mechanics which was not easy
took 27 years and two things happened we
realised that particles had wave-like
properties and fields had particle-like
properties and this was very confusing
and ultimately quantum mechanics unified
the two things so the thing that
happened first was this idea that fields
had particle-like properties okay so
James Clerk Maxwell in the mid-1800s
pointed out that electricity and
magnetism were two sides of the same
coin so we talked about the
electromagnetic field and what we
thought in the late 19th century was
that we had finally understood light it
wasn't particles it was a vibration and
oscillation in the electric and magnetic
fields but there were a couple of little
problems with that idea still hanging
around one is what was called blackbody
radiation take a hunk of matter doesn't
matter what it's made out of anything at
all put in an oven let it sit there for
a very long time so it comes to an
absolutely uniform temperature take it
out it'll be glowing because you've
heated it up look at all of the light
that it's emitting it's gonna admit some
long wavelength light some medium
wavelength light some short wavelength
light that's called blackbody radiation
so as physicists you want to say okay
let's explain that form of radiation and
they did the calculations and for
long wavelength light they got it
exactly right everything seemed to work
for the short wavelength light their
calculations were very clear everything
you put in the oven should be emitting
an infinite amount of short wavelength
light of ultraviolet of ultraviolet an
infinite amount according to the wave
calculations existed that's crazy so
they labeled it the ultraviolet
catastrophe all right and the problem
was semi solved by Max Planck whose name
I insist on pronouncing in German he
would have pronounced it even though I
don't say Einstein so I'm not consistent
and plunk said let's just imagine that
when light is emitted by the glowing
object it comes in discrete packets of
energy so if you know what the
wavelength is I will tell you how much
energy there is in a single discrete
packet long wavelength light has less
energy per little packet short
wavelength light has more energy and
then he got beautiful agreement he
predicted a new form of blackbody
radiation that agreed exactly with
whatever had been observed so the
distribution of light intensities at
different frequencies matched perfectly
if you figured that light was travelling
in packets honk didn't say light comes
in packets
he said light is emitted in packets so
Einstein in 1905 says well maybe that's
because light can only come in the form
of these little discrete energy packets
which we now call photons the particles
of light so the analogy I use is that
plunk was like saying I have a coffee
maker that you only push the button in
to makes you one cup of coffee never
makes half a cup of coffee or 2 cups of
coffee comes in discrete units of one
cup of coffee and Hein Stein says coffee
only exists in one cup size now that's a
much more dramatic claim but it was
consistent with everything and explained
even more than what Plunkett explained
now no one knew how to reconcile the
fact that Maxwell had this really good
successful theory of light as waves and
now plunk and Einstein you're saying
lights a particle but ok then it's Niels
Bohr who says actually particles have
kind of a field like behavior by then
Rutherford and others had realized what
the atom looks like so the atom is a
tiny little nucleus and electrons are
orbiting and every picture you see of an
atom look like a little solar system
like plan
orbiting the Sun but again physicists
want to understand this so they say well
wait a minute an electron orbiting that
means the electron is moving in a circle
or an ellipse that means the electron is
being jiggled back and forth and we know
what happens when you jiggle electrons
back and forth they emit light
that's what electrons do every photon
that you see around you right now is
because an electron was jiggling so you
can calculate what should happen to the
atom if the electron in its orbit emits
light the answer is the electron should
lose energy and spiral into the nucleus
in a tiny fraction of a microsecond it
should lose energy because it's emitting
light that uses its calories that's
right dad it should crash into the
nucleus and atoms shouldn't exist
exactly the atom should be completely
unstable this is a completely clear
unavoidable prediction of number one
classical mechanics
number two the idea that atoms look like
little solar systems electrons therefore
had to stop being particles in 1910 or
1912 all we know is that somehow
electrons and atoms don't behave like
they're supposed to Bohr comes with this
out of the blue suggestion when an
electron is orbiting an atom there's
only certain energies it can have and so
rather than spiraling down there is a
lowest energy orbit that the electron
can have and once it gets there it can't
move anymore and deburr lee who came
along afterwards said i can explain why
the electron has the lowest energy or
but because the electron is really a
wave and it's much like the vibrations
of a violin string or a guitar string
there's a fundamental there's the first
harmonic and second harmonic there's a
discrete set of wavelengths that a
vibrating string can have do Burleigh
says there's a discrete set of energies
the vibrating wave of the electron can
have so plunk and Einstein say waves
fields are kind of partically Bohr and
de Burleigh say particles like electrons
are kinda wavy that's 19-teens and then
in 1920s they reconcile at all it's all
quantum mechanics so let's get to the
heart of the matter the measurement
problem the source of so much of this
weirdness and confusion about what might
be going on to skip some very hard steps
the answer is
it's always okay that's a very short
answer that is really nothing partically
about even electrons photons electrons
quarks neutrinos are not particle at all
they're all waves but when we look at
them they look like particles and this
took a long time to sink in that there's
something about quantum mechanics that
you need to include some rules about
what happens when we look at it so the
measurement problem it's simple chord
the measurement problem is just at heart
stuff is described by a quantum wave but
when you measure it when you look at it
when you observe it that's not what you
see you see a particle that was never
true in classical mechanics there didn't
need to be separate rules for what
happened when you look at the classical
system you just see it it has a position
has a velocity you measure those okay so
there needed to be separate rules when
you observe the quantum wave function
here is what you will see now number one
why why do we need separate rules for
what's a measurement number two what
qualifies as a measurement does it have
to be a person doing the measurement
with a camera count and then the rules
that we actually have tell us that when
we observe the quantum system its
wavefunction changes instantly
dramatically and randomly by dint of our
observation yes this is what fits the
data that our observation changes the
quantum state right away called collapse
of the wavefunction so how quickly does
that happen is it really instantaneous
there's a long list of questions about
the measurement of quantum systems that
the standard quantum formalism simply
doesn't answer the thing that we teach
our undergraduates the thing that is
enshrined in textbooks when you measure
a quantum system you will see the
following thing with a certain
probability they will not say what it
means to measure something what happens
why it happens how it happens that's the
measurement problem so if an electron is
not a particle orbiting a Sun of sorts
what is it it's a wave function yeah
that's what it is and it's a cloud of
probabilities how do you describe that
typically let me just say that the
phrase wave function is the best we have
and it's terrible terrible yeah it is
terrible for one thing ordinary
ways that we know about exist in the
three-dimensional space around us at
every point in space there's a value for
the electric field the magnetic field
etc the wave function you should think
of as a sort of a machine you ask it a
question where is the electron for
example and it will say with a certain
probability you will find the following
answers to your question if all you care
about is the position of one electron
then the wave function at every point in
space it has a value and that value
tells you the probability of seeing the
electron there so if the electron is in
an atom the wave function is
concentrated right there in the atom
very close by to the nucleus and it
fades to zero very rapidly as you go
further away so it's a probability curve
of finding the electron at any given
point that's right that's why I
sometimes call it a cloud of probability
yeah it really is this fuzzy thing now
there's one big caveat there if you have
two electrons you don't have two clouds
and this is very very annoying but it's
also the secret to quantum mechanics if
you have two electrons rather than four
electron a I give you the probability of
finding anywhere and for electron B I
give you the probability of finding it
anywhere quantum mechanics says I need
to give you the probability for both
observations at the same time so for
every possible set of locations they
could both have there's a probability
let's talk about Newton and the fact
that position and velocity encompassed
everything well we comes down to an
electron we can't talk about either of
these things but sometimes in certain
cases we can pin down a position let's
talk about how that happens and how when
we pin down the position the velocity is
completely inaccessible to us and in
fact it doesn't even exist right already
in our discussion of quantum mechanics
we're at the point where there's nothing
I can say that someone won't disagree
with okay this is how bad it is we're
getting into the part of non-consensus
yeah exactly and it's not that you need
to go into very advanced questions all
you have to say is well what is the wave
function what does it mean is that what
the electron is or is that just part of
what the electron is or is it just our
knowledge of what the electron is nobody
agrees on these questions now I have a
point of view and
from now on in the conversation
everything I say will be assuming my
point of view and that point of view is
that the wavefunction is what is real
that's what actually exists it's not
that there is an electron and we don't
know where it is all there is is the
wavefunction the other point is more
technical which is okay when we talked
about a particle in Newtonian mechanics
you said there's a position and a
velocity and then when you were just
talking about the wavefunction of the
electron and he said there's a
probability for getting any position
what about the velocity so it turns out
that position and velocity are not
independent of each other anymore
so if you know for a Newtonian particles
position you know nothing about its
velocity right it could have any
velocity whatsoever all you knows where
it is but if I tell you the wave
function for an electron for every
single position the probability of
seeing it there you can figure out the
probability of observing any velocity
from the wave function given to you in
terms of position roughly speaking if
the wave function is oscillating rapidly
then the velocity is likely to be a
large number combining that
philosophical point the wave function is
what is real with that technical point
one determines the other you end up with
the uncertainty principle which is that
in my language all there is is the wave
function position and velocity are not
properties that electrons have they are
possible things you can measure so you
can measure the position or you can
measure the velocity but you're not
measuring pre-existing things you're
getting a result with a certain
probability and the way wave functions
work are if the position is very very
localized near to one point then you
have no idea what you're gonna get for
the velocity and vice versa if there's a
very certain velocity and the position
is spread out all over the place so the
uncertainty principle says there is no
quantum wave function for which both the
position and the velocity give you
definite answers so when you have an
observation just sort of put it in
simplistic language by the act of
observing you cause the electron to
suddenly look like a particle in a sense
you pin it down to one location at that
point in a sense yes the act of
observation makes it exist somewhere for
that moment that you're observing is
that fair
say that's as close as you're gonna get
once you've observed it in one place
its enormous ly probable that you're
gonna observe it right there that there
it is so in a sense the act of
observation concentrates all the
probabilities of where the electron may
be to something close to one point
that's right and instead of a cloud of
possibilities we have a hundred percent
or something that rounds to that
certainty that the electron is right
here right now but by having done that
we've drained any ability to know
anything about its velocity yeah that's
exactly right and then the other thing
that's vital is that it was not in any
one place until your observation in some
way coerced it into choosing a location
yeah that's right and the term that's
usually used as the collapse of the
wavefunction that's what happens when
you observe so when you observe it it
really collapses on whatever you observe
observe velocity then you would collapse
onto one velocity you basically take two
mysterious quantities and you say I'm
gonna know what one of them is that's
right and that's the part of the wave
function that has collapsed momentarily
and had you not observed or had you not
measured that would not have happened
that's exactly right
to give an example of how this plays out
in the laboratory well actually it
played out as a thought experiment for
decades but ultimately played out in the
laboratory could you describe
complementarity and the notorious double
slit experiment the double slit
experiment was a thought experiment that
was cooked up to help people realize how
weird quantum mechanics seems to our
intuition it was only fairly recently
done in the last couple decades and yeah
so the point is you have two slits in a
screen and you shoot some stuff at them
and then you observe what comes through
the slits at some detector on the other
side first imagine good old classical
pellets like a pellet gun and guess what
if you shoot them through two slits on
the other side you're gonna observe a
pattern of hits of the pellets that look
like two slits right because that's what
they pass through they basically
represent the shape of the slit the
pellet has to comment on a trajectory
that makes it through the slit so let's
say their paint pellets and you have a
big old canvas on the other side you're
gonna have to rectangle ish looking
shapes with a little bit of scatter
pattern around them
actly right whereas if you take your two
slits and put them in a tub of water and
slap one side of the water and let the
waves move out in a circle from where
you're slapping a wave can pass through
either one of the slits it breaks into
two waves breaks into two waves and they
will either constructively interfere so
they build up even higher than any one
of the waves themselves two peaks hit
each other and become a super peak or
they can destructively interfere so that
where one is peeking the other is
troughing and they cancel out and you
get nothing so you end up with a
semi-regular pattern of high amplitude
and low amplitude that's right as middle
of the other side of the slits you'll
see a big peak and then you'll see
littler Peaks fading as you go further
away from the middle so a very very
different pattern on your canvas than
you would have had with the pellet gun
yeah that's right so then you try it
with electrons you shoot the electrons
one at a time let's just shoot the
electrons one at a time why not the
point is you do detect them one at a
time on the other side you get a little
splat particle-like because when you
observe electrons they look like
particles right but you do this for many
electrons but one at a time like you
said and you observe the pattern of
splats and you might think that they
look like two slits just like the
classical pellets did they don't they
look like the wave pattern that you got
when you put water through the waves so
even though they're shooting out one at
a time they ain't waves in the
traditional way of thinking about it you
wouldn't think that they were you
wouldn't think that they're waves you're
firing them one at a time and over
hundreds or thousands or however many
you send out they end up imitating this
interference pattern of waves of water
going through as opposed to actual
single pellets every electron is
interfering with itself which is
something that waves do not something
that particles do ah which makes perfect
sense if you think that electrons are
really waves and that you made an
observation at the detector so so far
that's fine but to drive home the
weirdness you can say well what if like
measure which slit the electron goes
through because if I believe the
electrons are waves it had to go through
both slits so now I want to see which
slid it goes through so I'm going to put
a detector there and measure did the
charge go through one slit
the other and you're expecting at this
point that it's gone through both
because it's wave except you've never
observed half of an electron anywhere
right when you observe it you force it
to be in one lo exactly the electron
will go through either one slit or the
other you will never observe it going
through both slits and when you look at
the pattern on the screen on the other
side the interference has gone away now
that you're measuring which lip the
electron goes through it acts in a
purely particle-like way and you get the
same kind of pattern on the other side
that you got when you shot a classical
pellet gun through two big slits so
again as we were saying earlier by
looking you have forced it into a
position and this is manifesting itself
on the actual photographic paper or
whatever is on the other side that's
detecting the pattern of the landings
and when this was first discovered I
suppose that a lot of people thought wow
does this mean there's something strange
about consciousness and the fact that
we're observing this is having this
clear impact on matter and it knows when
we're looking and it knows when we're
not and it behaves one way when we're
looking and it behaves another way when
we're not well it was certainly an
implication or a possible direction you
could go down as soon as it became clear
that making sense of quantum mechanics
required separate rules for the active
observation or measurement without
specifying what that meant the door was
open for someone to say well look
observers are conscious creatures I bet
that human consciousness has some effect
on the wave function of the electron
that changes it when we observe it and
the double slit experiment is just an
especially vivid demonstration of that
idea let's talk about spin because
that's in some ways a simplifying thing
an electron will essentially have two
spin States correct that's right and
it's either up or down by the language
yes yes right so you have some magnetic
field and you pass an electron through
it and it will either be deflected
upward or deflected downward along the
axis defined by that magnetic field this
is again a situation in which you pin
the electron down and it either has to
be up or down that's right and it's the
act of observation that makes it up or
down
yep exactly prior to that was in
superposition could explain what
superposition is both when we're talking
about spin and also when we're talking
about location the idea of a
superposition is the electron is in
every possible position that's what it
means to say the electron has a wave
function these are supposed to be two
synonymous ways of speaking you might
say there's a wave function I could
calculate the probability of observing
the electron there or I could say the
electron is in a superposition of every
possible position it's in all of those
positions at one that's it's in some of
them more than others that means there's
more probability for seeing it there and
notionally before we measure the spin of
the electron
it's neither up nor down just like we
expressed the wave function of the
electron as saying to every possible
position we could observe those are the
probability it's much simpler when we
only think of the spin because there's
an infinite number of answers we could
get to the position of the electron yes
but there's only two answers we can get
to the question what do we observe the
spin to be so the so-called wave
function for the spin of the electron is
just a number associated with spin up
and a separate number associated with
spin down and is it 50/50 generally who
knows I mean whatever we want before it
goes through the magnet that causes it
to make a choice could you say these
electrons here are 90% likely to be up
and 10% likely to be down where those
are 90% likely to be down in 10% likely
to be up yeah we can prepare electrons
in whatever wave functions we want so we
can easily make them 90% up 10% down oh
that's interesting
so what are some of the popular
explanations of what happens when we
collapse the wave function and establish
that an electron is up versus down well
first I'll tell you some version of what
we call the Copenhagen interpretation
this is what became enshrined in 1927
and is taught to our undergraduates ever
since which is basically don't ask that
question there is something called
observation is something called
measurement it's not explained in terms
of other things it is a fundamental part
of quantum mechanics it is roughly
compatible with what you think you have
a microscope or a particle accelerator
or whatever and the wavefunction just is
a black box that tells you the
probability and wave functions collapse
instantly when you make a measurement
if the electron was spin up plus bend
down 50/50 if you measured to be spin up
the spin down miss of it went away once
and for all disappeared
okay many worlds which was invented by
Hugh Everett who's a graduate student of
Princeton the 1950s it says the
following thing if you look at what
we're taught by our elders are the rules
of quantum mechanics there are wave
functions they evolve according to the
Schrodinger equation evolution is that
the probabilities ebb and flow at
different places that's right according
to a very definite equation so the
classical mechanics is the state of a
system where its positions and
velocities and they evolve according to
Newton's laws but then the rules of
quantum mechanics tack on more rules
when you observe it you get certain
outcomes with certain probabilities the
wavefunction collapses Everett says what
if I just erased all of those extra
rules what if the rules of quantum
mechanics were just there are wave
functions and they obey the Schrodinger
equation by any sensible measure that's
a simpler theory the rules are much more
compact the problem is it doesn't seem
to match our observations because wave
functions seem to collapse but ever it
says look think about that spin
measurement that you're doing the
electron is spin up or spin down what
you're forgetting is that you the
experimenter live in the universe and
the universe runs by the rules of
quantum mechanics so you obey the rules
of quantum mechanics in particular you
can evolve into super positions just
like electrons can it's nothing special
about you you're made of electrons and
protons and neutrons after all so what
happens to you when you measure the spin
of the electron when the electron starts
out in a superposition a little bit of
both you are a little bit of both
there's a little bit of the universe
that says the electron was spin up and
you saw it spin up and there's a little
bit of the universe that says the
electron was spin down and you saw it
spin down the problem is that's not how
we feel none of us has ever felt like oh
I'm kind of in a superposition of having
seen the electron spin up and the
electron spin down and Everett's he said
you are not the combination of both the
person who saw spin up and the person
who saw spin down when you did that
measurement the wave function of the
universe went from describing one
world to describing two worlds one in
which the electron would spin up and you
saw it spin up and the other of which
the electron was spin down and you saw
it spin down they're both there
there are now two people the universe
has split it has branched and I have
answered the measurement problem what's
a measurement a measurement is whenever
a tiny quantum system in a superposition
interacts with a big macroscopic system
and becomes entangled with it this
situation where there's electrons spin
up and you saw it spin up plus there's
electron spin down plus you saw it spin
down is entanglement the state of you is
now entangled with the spin of the
electron so if I can put this in my own
terms I'm getting ready to measure the
spin of a perfectly innocent
unsuspecting electron no idea what's
coming and the universe contains a
single me and this ambiguous electron
from my standpoint yes this electron
with this mysterious Penn State then I
make the measurement and now there is a
rob who has seen an electron that spin
up and somewhere else there is a rob who
saw it in the spin down state exactly
and I got tangled up with that electron
in a very literal sense you became
entangled that electron yes because my
observation forced it in a sense to make
a choice it actually didn't make a
choice it's still both things but now
there have to be two of me in order to
contain the two observations that's
right and had I not made that
observation that electron would still be
in its ambiguous state and there would
still be one of me now we have a real
definite physical theory so we can say
what do you mean by making a measurement
how quickly does it happen etc so we
know what it means when it's you and the
electron what about if it's a video
camera and the electron and the answer
came along in the form of what we now
called decoherence which was pioneered
by hans teetered say in the 1970s so
let's say that there's the electron
there's you and there's what we call the
environment literally everything else in
the universe the electron can maintain
its superposition without becoming
entangled with the environment the
electron can stay in a superposition you
as a big macroscopic thing will become
and
with the environment so now we can
finally answer the question when does a
measurement happen a measurement happens
when the quantum system becomes
entangled with this environment a
previously unentangled quantum system
that's right so we have an electron that
is isolated enough from the environment
that it is in superposition yep that it
is in effect both spin up and spin down
and if it's teamed up with an atom it is
in effect in all positions at once to
differing degrees based on probability
how hard is it to isolate an electron to
that degree it's impossible to isolate
me I'm getting hit by gazillions of
photons at all times our most electrons
inherently disentangled and it's a
rarity that one of them gets entangled
because they're so tiny and isolated
once you have an unentangled electron if
it's only that one electron not too hard
to keep it unentangled from everything
else especially if the electron is in an
atom the atom is contain the system to
get entangled you need to have different
parts of your wavefunction interact with
the rest of the world differently so to
a large extent things remain unentangled
so if I'm a electron and let's say a
carbon atom there's a lot of electrons
and a carbon atom on one of the inner
shells right probably nothing's ever
gonna preserve me I will be in a
disentangled state for perhaps billions
of years that's right but I don't want
to give people the impression that the
wave function doesn't branch very often
yeah for a lot of electrons they may
stay in superposition for billions of
years but boy are there a lot of
electrons in the universe but also there
are things like nuclei giving off
radioactivity how much radioactivity
does the typical human body give off do
you have a guess like measuring what how
many times per second does a radioactive
decay happen in your body not being made
of lutonium your uranium I would assume
it's a low number but the question
you've asked suggests it's a shockingly
high number so I'm gonna go with 800
times per second 5000 times per second
Wow I was in the ballpark yeah your
order of magnitude but that's a lot for
sites a lot so the wave function the
universe branches in two to five
thousand times a second just because of
radioactive atoms in your body so that
is a lot of you know in the universe
there's a lot of branches because every
one of those five thousand is
yes or no choice it did decay or did not
right there's a branch in which a
decayed a branch would you did not yeah
and then every human body every planet
etc etc so there is a great deal of
branching yes that is going on that's
right the core mystery that needs to be
explained is why do things act
differently when they're being observed
yeah and why is it that macroscopic
objects like us don't seem to exhibit
these behaviors but if you get down to
the electron scale they do are those the
two questions that the competing
explanations of which many-worlds is one
are those the two fundamental things
that need to be explained or is there
one or two other things that a
non-scientific mind can grasp there are
a bunch of things that need to be
explained but you put your finger on two
good ones the thing that gets attention
as the measurement problem now you've
mentioned this other problem why does
the world look approximately classical
right why is in quantum mechanics very
evident in our everyday lives to me
that's a very good question that is
underappreciated even in foundations of
physics circles so let me give some of
the other answers to the measurement
problem and you'll see what I mean
there are two other very respectable
popular approaches to the measurement
problem one is called dynamical collapse
dynamical collapse theories say the wave
functions usually evolve according to
the Schrodinger equation but not always
for every particle there is a chance
every second that whatever its
wavefunction is doing it will
spontaneously and randomly collapse so
we'll go from being spread out in
position to being highly concentrated at
one location so once in a very long
while this will occur about once every
300 million years for any given electron
even Elect but given the number of
electrons in my body that would be
happening all the time exactly so 300
million years is chosen very carefully
is it derived mathematically or did they
pick an arbitrary number that was
convenient
no they checked the number that wouldn't
be ruled out okay god if it were once a
second then individual electrons in your
lab would just be collapsing all the
time and you would have noticed that a
long time ago if it were much longer
then even a relatively large system
wouldn't collapse so
the beauty of the dynamical collapse
theories is that in any one object like
a table or you or me all the electrons
are entangled with each other such that
when one of them collapses the others
sort of jiggle along with it one of them
collapses spontaneously therefore all
the electrons in this arbitrary object
the table are also in sympathy or in
domino effect they too will momentarily
have a specified position exactly right
so imagine you could take a bowling ball
and put it in a quantum superposition of
being here and being a meter away okay
two different physical locations in
dynamical collapse theories if any one
of the electrons in the bowling ball
suddenly collapses either to here or to
one meter away all the other electrons
and all the protons and neutrons go with
it
so we've sort of imposed classical
behavior on the world that sort of
anchors large objects to behave in
Newtonian manner that's right and they
picked it once every 300 million year
number because that conveniently anchors
anything big enough for us to see but
it's rare enough that if you decide to
test it you're gonna have to sit in your
lab for 300 million years so good luck
disproving that or you make a collection
of a hundred thousand or a million atoms
and you wait patiently what about a
collection of 300 million we don't need
to keep them very very cool and isolated
from the rest of the world and not
becoming entangled with photons in the
room or anything like that
that's very very hard to do so what
people are actually doing is getting
tiny sets of something very very cool
probably liquid helium or something and
this process of an electron
spontaneously collapsing will gently
heat up the material okay so it adds
energy to the system and that's
observable and they're testing that
right now so somebody who's trying to
test this oh yeah absolutely right
they're doing a very good job are the
people doing it from the camp that
generally believes in this and would
rather like to prove it or are they from
the camp that is sick of hearing about
this crap and would like to disprove it
I'm sure they would like to prove it
Nobel Prizes would be falling down on
their heads
this grw is that what this series called
grw uh Girardi Romanian and Weber were
three of the people who first proposed
version of this theory but it's in this
larger set of theories called dynamical
collapse theories so that's one approach
there's another called hidden variables
yes and this is more venerable this is
what Louie de Burleigh had in mind and
what Albert Einstein had in mind and
even what Hermann Schrodinger had in
mind back in the day they said look I
have light it has wave-like properties
and particle-like properties let me just
do the obvious thing say that that's
because there's both a particle and a
wave and the theory was later discovered
and extended by David Bohm in the 1950s
so now it's often called de broglie-bohm
theory or even just bohmian mechanics
so now electrons are really particles
they had positions but you don't know
what they are the probability in quantum
mechanics just comes from your ignorance
you don't know where the electron is the
wavefunction is a whole separate thing
and the electron interacts with the
wavefunction and the way that it
interacts is it gets funneled into where
the wavefunction is big so you're more
likely to observe it where the
wavefunction is big than where the
wavefunction is small there are two
elements to reality there's the
locations of the particles and there's
the wavefunction so in your view of
things the electron simply does not have
a position in their view the electron
always has a position we just don't
happen to know what it is that's right
and then one of my favorite ones because
I really love Picasso is cubism of
course that has nothing to do with
Picasso nothing at all but could you
give us a quick zippy tour of what
cubism says about this odd behavior well
if ever it says okay there's a
wavefunction and it evolved smoothly
according the Schrodinger equation so
how could that possibly not be the right
answer well one thing is there could be
things beside the wavefunction and that
gets you hidden variable theories
another thing could be the wave function
doesn't always evolve smoothly and that
gets you dynamical collapse theories the
third option is there's a wave function
but it's not the real physical stuff of
reality what the wave function is is an
especially mathematically elaborate way
of characterizing our ignorance it's a
way of being Bayesian about things
there's a probability of anything
happening you have a credence for any
proposition you might want to have
and the wave function is just a tool for
calculating your personal credence that
the electron will be seen to be spin up
rather than spin down so does this bring
consciousness into the equation because
there's something in cubism called
participatory realism which again sounds
like a form of painting yes so does
human consciousness start getting
integrated in cubism yes and no and look
I have tried very hard to understand
cubism and I don't I'm not sympathetic
so there might be some metal preventing
me from doing it what I can say is that
if you ask a cubist to lay out you know
the rules of cubism unlike any of the
other options that we've talked about
the idea of an agent who has experiences
and makes observations is intrinsically
part of the formalism so it does kind of
sound like consciousness and you hold
this in our part what is an agent I
don't know the answer to that is right
but I have trouble understanding these
because you ain't no cute I'm not a
cubist but they are biting that bullet
in many worlds is obviously a radical
view because of all those worlds that it
implies okay dynamical collapse is a
radical view because it makes the laws
of physics truly an inextricably random
hidden variables is probably the least
radical it just says their stuff we
haven't found yet yeah it's the version
of quantum mechanics that is closest to
classical mechanics it's the least crazy
thing crazy not an enormity sentence but
just in a deviation from previous ways
of thinking since cubism is the biggest
crazy thing it says we shouldn't be in
the job of talking about reality reality
comes into existence as a result of our
observations but it doesn't pre-exists
the job of physics is not describing
reality it's to predict observational
outcomes that is a hugely dramatic
metaphysical shift it is science and
what we're doing here and I think it's
too big a shift it's unwarranted because
we have perfectly realist versions of
quantum mechanics that fit the data and
what's an agent you know right why is it
agents seem to agree on the world if it
doesn't pre-exists them and things like
that so it's really difficult for me to
take it seriously on the other hand they
find it difficult to take many world
series
right there's a symmetry there there is
a symmetry there so if we took let's say
a thousand academic physicists chose an
entirely at random and asked them which
of these theories do you adhere to
how many would say I don't know and I
don't care it just doesn't interest me
so not I think that'd be the winner
that'd be the weight I put if you asked
that question at a cosmology conference
or a quantum information conference or a
condensed matter conference you're gonna
get very different answers there is
sympathy for many worlds among people
with cosmology or quantum gravity
interests in the quantum information
theory community where you're doing
things like building quantum computers
and stuff lithography yeah cryptography
stuff like that
there's surprising sympathy for cubism
and you can kind of understand that
that's what they're doing they're
measuring outcomes there are agents
getting experiences calculating
probabilities for them that's what they
do and in the philosophy of physics
community dynamical collapse and hidden
variable theories are the most popular
ones and you can understand that as well
because they're perfectly well
formulated theories that don't have any
metaphysical conundrums associated with
them the thing that just intuitively is
most difficult to accept about many
worlds is that these vast expanses
populated by perhaps octillion zuv
conscious systems are just propagating
constantly just intuitively I think most
people who are hearing about the theory
for the first time would basically leave
it at that and maybe to put it in more
formalistic terms you'd say conservation
of matter and energy this seems to be
creating an awful lot of something out
of nothing or a awful lot of something
out of a lone universe yeah and I think
is a perfectly valid first intuition to
have but then you got to go through the
math and if you buy in too many worlds
this current state of the universe you
see around you is just one branch of the
wavefunction and that branch comes with
what we call a weight the wavefunction
says is this branch big or small is it
thick or thin that's it the likely or
unlikely is it a probability statement
no it's there with a hundred percent so
when you have the electron and spin up
plus spin down and the universe evolves
into a combination of both spin up and
spin
basically it's not like you're taking
the universe and doubling it it's like
you're taking the universe and slicing
it in half and now there's two universes
but they're each half the size of the
original universe every time you branch
the wavefunction the total thickness of
the wavefunction doesn't change this
thickness this is not something that's
easily measurable I assume well you can
prepare something like the electron wave
function in any superposition you want
like we talked about right 1% up 99%
down etc so you know what it is so then
once you measure it you know what the
thickness is of the two branches that
have been created but once they've been
created you can't measure it yeah and it
just seems that whatever arbitrary
thickness we assigned to the universe
let's say and New Year's Day midnight
1950 it has an arbitrary thickness it's
a state at that instant the number of
times it's been split since then it's
not infinite but god it's a lot of times
I mean if every single time there's
radioactive decay in my body and that's
five thousand times a second yeah and
there's all these bodies and there's all
these planets and we can only see 14
billion light years in either direction
it probably goes further than that with
all of those splittings happening
whatever thickness the world had in 1950
it is such a miniscule sliver of it at
some point you kind of run into Zeno's
paradox don't you well maybe maybe not
and the one thing that we don't know
when this is sort of an embarrassing
admission for an ever ed Ian we don't
know whether an infinite or finite
number of branches of the wave function
of the universe we only know that simple
basic fact and to be fair in no version
of quantum mechanics do we know whether
there are an infinite or finite number
of different distinguishable wave
functions this is a deep question about
quantum gravity and the wave function of
the universe
so there's physics we don't understand
that we would need to know before we
said there's only a finite number of
branches versus an infinite number of
branches but having said all that
there's plenty of room for lots of
branches you can ask yourself if the
universe just keeps branching at this
fantastic rate will we run out of room
for branches no we're nowhere close it's
a really really big number if there are
an infinite number of dimensions in what
we call a Hilbert space the space of all
possible
functions then the question of how many
branches there are in many worlds makes
no sense it's always an infinite number
and what you should be asking instead is
what is the relative fraction of worlds
where the electron will spin up versus
the electron has spin down and a quick
aside the term for someone who adheres
to this school of thought
do you prefer many worlds ER or ever
read e'en ever-ready in his fine
ever-ready and yeah it has a nice ring -
yeah it sounds a little like the battery
every by the way is a fascinating guy
yeah let's talk about him briefly cuz he
for somebody who had such a big academic
idea he did not say in academia for long
he didn't even try he didn't apply for
jobs while he was still a graduate
student he wrangled a job in a sort of
defense consulting firm and got his PhD
and left and it's unclear to me whether
or not that was because he was put off
by the bad reception that his theory
gone because it certainly did get a bad
reception it got a bad reception as he
was writing his dissertation yes that's
right this was in the 50s I mean ok
fifties his PhD adviser was John Wheeler
Oh who is the most successful PhD
advisor in history of physics Richard
Feynman was his student Kip Thorne was
his student and whoever it was a student
and plenty others as well and wheelers
mentor was guess who Niels Bohr they'd
worked together when wheeler was a
postdoc and so forth and to the extent
that physicists worship each other
wheeler worship for and so real er was
stuck in the position where his mentor
was the boss of the Copenhagen
interpretation his student had just
invented its primary competitor so
wheeler tried really hard to pretend
that these two theories were not in
conflict with each other and the problem
was that was obviously false they were
very much in conflict and Evert
understood that perfectly you read what
he wrote and it's perfectly clear he was
a genius he knew exactly what he was
talking about if he were alive today he
would walk right into conversations
about the foundations of quantum
mechanics and fit right in and so he saw
that his theory was a competitor to Bohr
he saw all the problems with the
Copenhagen interpretation he laid them
out Evert left the field in 1957 when he
got his PhD thesis published and then as
late as the late
seven DS wheeler was still trying to get
Everett back into academic physics he
died young right he died young his early
50s he was a smoker and a drinker and an
eater his son mark has become a famous
musician he is the band called eels oh
right yeah I can do that yeah and uh
wrote a book you know a little bit of
autobiography Memoirs and Mark Everett
explained that he was very angry with
his father when he died because he
clearly didn't take care of himself
mm-hmm but then he said you know since
then I realized a lot of people died for
bad reasons and my father lived the way
he wanted to and had a good time and
there's a lot worse ways to go than that
but that contribution you still call
yourselves ever-ready ins yeah it was
clear who did the work how many of you
are there I honestly don't know the
theory was completely ignored for a
number of years after Everett proposed
it it was eventually Bryce DeWitt who
was a physicist in the University of
Texas who in the early 1970s he began to
publicize it he's the one who gave it
the many-worlds interpretation label but
it never became very very popular and
then partly because of improvements in
technology now that we have the ability
to isolate individual quantum systems
and ask what they do to each other not
simply measure them but manipulate them
without measuring them without having
them picot hearing we need to understand
the foundations of quantum mechanics
better so in the physics community as a
whole there's been a softening of their
stance that studying the foundations of
quantum mechanics is a bad idea and so
all of the interpretations quantum
mechanics are getting more attention now
than they ever did including Everett and
roughly how many are taken seriously are
there four or five rivals are there
fifteen or sixteen you know I was on a
panel at the World Science Festival a
few years ago Brian Greene was the
moderator and there were four other
people and I was one of them and we each
held up the flag for an approach to
interpreting quantum mechanics you each
had a different interpreting
shelly goldstein was hidden variables
David Albert was dynamical collapse
Ruettiger shock was cubism now was that
by prearrangement that was the theme of
the panel gods right yeah and I think
that that's fair I think of those four
approaches are the most popular
okay I'd like to talk about the self in
many worlds because that's one of the
most intriguing things that pops out of
it the notion that there are octillion
of me yeah quote-unquote out there it is
the right thing to think about because
it is where many worlds radically
deviates from our previous experience
with physics right if you believe
whatever it says then when I measure the
spin of the electron there goes from
being one copy me to being two copies of
me and it's natural to ask myself to
question before I do that measurement
which one will I end up being the one
who measured the spin up or the one who
measured the spin down there will be two
of you except with a little footnote
they won't be of you in exactly the same
sense there are two versions of your
future self but they're separate people
in Everett introduced this analogy it's
like an amoeba yeah it's a really good
analogy right yeah there's an amoeba and
it splits in two and then there's two
amoebas and for the original meeple to
say which one am I gonna be you're gonna
be both of them there are separate
beings that came from the same original
being and they also have memories and
memories of being the original me about
us and then thousands of generations of
amoeba could all have equal claim to
saying I'm the original what does it
mean to have a relationship between you
now and you five minutes ago or five
years ago because in some sense you now
is not the same you as five years ago
you know we're a slightly different
person but in everyday life we have no
trouble relating ourselves okay but if
you sit down and carefully ask well what
is that relationship between you now and
you five years ago you might say well
like you said continuity of memories
continuity of some physical aspects
there's a pattern that is maintained
over time so it's not that there's any
problems with the issue of personal
identity in many worlds it's just
different than what it would be in a
single world theory so let's say that
I'm in the lab and now I have a choice
to make I'm going to observe the spin-up
or spin-down and no that is a direct
consequence of that there are gonna be
twice as many Me's of this art a huge
number but you know there's gonna be
twice as many Me's going forward and
let's say okay I do that and then
there's the up me and the down me that
is such a trivial experience and that's
such a trivial factor in the way the
universe is gonna unfold whether that
electron would spin up or spin down it
would seem logical that those two Rob's
would go on to live almost identical
lives yeah yeah unless they thought
ahead of time you know spin is up I'm
gonna ask her to marry me and it's
finished down I'm gonna go and be single
right and then went ahead and did that
that's right
which brings us the app can we split the
universe right now we can let's split
the universe and first explain what the
app is yeah this is some folks who
actually worked for Walt Disney in their
spare time they made a little app which
splits the wavefunction in the universe
so as we know splitting the wavefunction
universe happens all the time because
the radioactivity or whatever but you
can do it intentionally one good way of
doing it intentionally is sending a
photon into what's called a beam
splitter a beam splitter is basically a
piece of glass which is sort of half way
mirror half reflective yeah so there's a
50% chance the photon bounces to the
left
50% chance it just goes right on through
since this is a quantum observation by
operating the app as we're about to do
you cause a photon that would not
otherwise have been beam split to beam
split exactly right they found online a
lab that it hooked up a beam splitter to
the Internet and you can send it a query
you can say please send a photon down
and tell me whether it went right or
left and all they did was write a little
front-end for that thing where they call
it universe splitter and there are two
options is a default which says take a
chance or play it safe but you can edit
those you can say should I have pizza
for dinner or should I have Chinese food
for dinner let's say snap once her snap
twice I'm snapping my fingers snap one
or snap twice and so you're entering it
now yep and you basically click a button
and it sends a little signal to this
laboratory it's in Geneva and it flashes
and it says that the photon did the
thing which predicts that you should now
snap twice all right there you go so
that is a high consequence quantum
events a big macroscopic difference
between the two branches of the
wavefunction and one of them you snapped
only once and the other one you snap
twice do you want to talk about the 50
number string that you put into your
book yeah so to make this vivid I went
online and found a quantum random number
and used it to generate a 50 digit
binary number it looks like I randomly
typed in zeros and ones
it sure does I can attest to that I
agreed with myself my past self agreed
my future self to whatever I generated
in that random number I was gonna put in
the book and this was not a simple
random number generator this was a
quantum non toom random number generator
one confusion about many worlds is the
idea that every time you make a decision
the world branches that's not how it
works
anytime a quantum system in
superposition becomes entangled with its
environment the universe branches this
is very specifically a quantum random
number generator which takes a quantum
system measures it in a basis where it
was 50/50 one way or the other so 2 to
the power 50 is the number of possible
binary numbers I could have generated
and if you believe many worlds there's
that many branches of the wave function
which is about a quadrillion metal
quadrillion and so what's unusual about
this is you allowed this quantum event
to have an impact on the macroscopic
world all of your quadrillion compadres
were committed to the same project that
means that there are literally
quadrillion versions of this book in the
Metaverse yes and it's probably unique
in that unless something else is done
the same one of my favorite stories
about George Church do you know George I
know who he is I had met him once he's
certainly one of the most influential by
engineers in the world and when he wrote
his book he basically encoded it in DNA
and then amplified it to the point where
there are more copies of it than any
other book ever written including the
Bible but next time I see George I gotta
tell him
but there aren't quadrillion versions of
it the versions are all the same yeah
yeah his versions are all the same I
forgot to actually do it I thought about
asking to put it on the title page where
like it says edition no they put like I
would convert that binary number into a
decimal number and say it's this edition
how did you forget to do that it's not
too late I'll try no it's not you're
still in copy editing you really really
should do that if you believe ever once
again the vast majority of the copies of
me got a pretty random looking number
right mine was I think 24 zeroes and 26
ones or something else what you would
expect right now and if it were all
zeroes
and one of the quadrillion got all zero
one of them did and one of the
quadrillions got all ones one of them
got zero one zero one zero one got a
very repeated path there's a certain
tiny fraction of the quadrillion numbers
that look weird to us yeah they're
created equal in some broader sense but
they look weird to us and since every
single one of them by definition had to
play out somewhere there are some arms
of the Sean Carol branch whose life did
diverge because they said this thing's
not working right they said [ __ ] I can't
put that in the book yeah they do the
experimenting and get another number
with overwhelming probability would look
normal well let's say that the next
thing you do if you get all zeroes the
one in quadrillion sean's says I better
do it again yeah now you've got
quadrillion more who've done it again
and one of those guys definitely got all
zeroes again exactly that's right yeah
so this is one of the true conundrums of
many worlds somewhere in the wave
function of the universe someone is
going to get the wrong answer someone is
going to be misled about how the world
works it's a tiny tiny tiny tiny
fraction to people but it will happen
the same exact thing would be true if
our universe is infinite in space so
there's a lot of planets with a lot of
physicists on them somewhere in space
there's someone who does the quantum
random number generator over and over
again and gets a weird answer right so
that's just life in a probabilistic
universe could you talk about the
Russian Roulette thought experiment it's
a little macabre but since nobody
actually did it I think it's fair to
talk about it I think whoever believed
in a version of it interesting sometimes
called quantum immortality right which
sounds better than quantum suicide which
is what it's often called it's one of
those ideas much like cubism that I
don't buy so I do a bad job of giving
the sales pitch but let's imagine you
had a machine that was sort of like
Schrodinger's cat esque where there was
a quantum measurement with some
probability 5050 that either nothing
would happen to you or you would
instantly be killed it spin up it says
oh you're lucky you got spin up if it's
spin down you're instantly killed you
die instantly feel not having to be
instant ya know suffering and death yeah
if that's possible that's okay it's a
thought experiment right we saw the
sopranos I'm convinced that's what
happened in the last thing we do
actually yeah if you think that
your future self is the set of all of
your descendants in the wavefunction on
all the different branches there's one
branch in which there you are there's a
future descendent of you sudo lives spin
up but there isn't a version of you on
the other branch because that version
died so in some sense all of your future
cells are still alive well in a sense
yeah in a sense yeah yeah yeah that's
interesting going forward from that
point the survivor is gonna branch so
goddamn many times because of the nature
of the universe there's still going to
be just the gazillions of them by
construction the branches where you
exist or branches where you're alive and
so in some sense you never die if you
take the preposterous idea that your
sudden death would have no impact on the
well-being of your loved ones then you
might say there's no cost to me doing
this because I could sit in that machine
have the contraption go off a hundred
times so the odds of surviving on one
way of looking at is two to the
hundredth of power but my conscious
experience is simply going to be a
hundred misfires and then I go out often
have my normal day that's right and when
tegmark discussed this his point was the
one who survived would have a good
reason to believe the Everett
interpretation right that was the thing
that I thought was clever like if you
did go through that experience yeah and
the gun went off
a hundred times right then you would
definitely be a committed many world
theory so that was the ID at the end of
it let's imagine a couple changes to
this scenario first let's make it more
humane and there's not a gun going off
the horn sounds so either the horn
sounds or it doesn't sound and then
could we set it up in such a way that
the odds are much more extreme so we
could say it's not 50/50 it's one in a
thousand sure say it's a one in a
thousand chance that something very
improbable is gonna happen to me which
is I'm gonna hit this button and hear a
horn I hit the button it's a quantum of
event so the universe Cleaves into two
one of the two new Me's here's the horn
and one of them doesn't now what's weird
to me about that is for the one who
hears the horn there was essentially a
50% chance that he was going to have
this exotic experience as some probable
experience because the universe Cleaves
into two right now it doesn't it Cleaves
and
thousands into - but that does not imply
a 50/50 chance those two branches have
very different thicknesses they have
different thicknesses so tell me what
that means this is a crucial point yeah
was this is the single most respectable
anti ever ready an argument really I
just came up with it just came up with
it even for positions I don't hold
there's some arguments for them I find
more interesting so this is a
respectable one
this is the biggest problem is cast it
that way the biggest problem they've
already in quantum mechanics is that
everything happens yes it's not that
some things happen rarely and some
things happen infrequently and every
measurement outcome happen there's only
two and they're disproportionate
percentage possibilities that's
radically disproportion yes that's yeah
so the question is in what sense is
there a probability at all in everybody
in quantum mechanics in Copenhagen when
you observe the system there's a
probability given by the wave function
squared and anti ever-ready and say look
there shouldn't be any probability in
Eveready in quantum mechanics everything
happens with the hundred percent
probability somewhere when I think about
the thousand to one split we have caused
something to happen in the Metaverse
that has taken one observer and turned
it into two and the chance that either
of those two observers since the total
number of observers is to heard the horn
in each case is fifty percent no that's
just not right and so that's where this
thing of thickness is yeah so the
observers are not created equal if I
slice a loaf of bread into two yeah and
I ask what is the probability that a
certain atom is in one part of the bread
or the other part it depends on where I
sliced it I didn't say I sliced it
halfway in the middle well yeah yeah way
over one edge there's now two pieces of
bread that doesn't mean 50/50
probability but if both of these
descendants of the observer are in every
way shape and form experience opinions
what they're wearing atomic
configuration identical to one another
yeah
in what way does one have a thousand
times the weight of the other how does
that manifest itself they can't see it
like we already said you can't see what
your amplitude is you can't do a
measurement to notice it right but if
you believe the rules of quantum
mechanics and you knew what the
wavefunction was before you did the
measurement you could know what that
amplitude is yeah but it's the one that
makes the universe make sense it's the
amplitude
makes energy conservation work that
makes probability work everything goes
in exactly the same way
okay that's fascinating I firmly believe
that it all makes sense and what I'm
saying is true on the other hand I don't
want to denigrate the idea that this is
weird and tough and we should struggle
with it like I said it's the good worry
to have good well I'm glad I hit on the
right one there yeah now the other
question that I have is a lot of the
Metaverse theories that are out there
talk about there being some kind of
higher dimensional space in which
universes exist you do not specifically
when we first talked about this several
weeks ago and I asked you where the
various clone universes are your answer
was nowhere yeah now comparing that to
the brain theory and listeners this
theory spells brain BR a and E it's
short for membrane the brain Theory has
it that our three spatial dimension
universe exists in a much higher
dimensional space called the bulk which
contains lots and lots and lots of these
brains which can at times even collide
with each other and so there are lots of
universes but they were inaccessible to
us they're in a dimension that we cannot
travel in there is remote is remote can
be but there is this notion of a higher
dimensional space in which they coexist
you don't believe that well it's not
that I don't believe that is that the
many-worlds is a completely separate
idea so within the many-worlds view the
clone universe is I think you said is
nowhere yeah that's right so very
quickly in the brain example it's not
that they exist in a much higher
dimensional space there's like a couple
extra dimensions right that's one way to
have a cosmological multiverse but it's
not the only way the most popular way is
just there are regions of space far away
in our three dimensions where things
look very different really I've heard of
you know the notion of inflation
creating a universe of de-facto infinite
extent right and there being many clones
of me at great distances does that
version also hold that there might be
different physical laws applying a
different yes oh I didn't realize that's
right can the cat doesn't have to but it
can so the string theory landscape the
cosmological multiverse the anthropic
principle they all use that same basic
idea and actually compared to many
worlds that's sort of a very
down-to-earth wave
multiverse right there just regions far
away where things look different whereas
many worlds says there are very very
large copies of exactly the same
universe and they're being created all
the time you're in this room and they
exist if anywhere in an abstract
mathematical space called Hilbert space
which is the set of all possible quantum
states the universe could be in and it
has the structure of a vector space as a
dimensionality right like space around
us is three-dimensional tabletop is
two-dimensional etc in string theory the
number of dimensions of space is
something like 10 or 9 depending on the
dial and eversion exactly hilbert space
has a dimensionality it might be
infinite dimensional at least the
minimum possible number for the
dimensionality of Hilbert space is 2 to
the 10 to the 120 2 very large number a
huge number which is why there's no
danger of running out of room that
number is that big enough if we think of
the total number of particles in the
observable universe is 10 to the 80th or
something like class plenty big so it
would accommodate the collapsing of any
wave function we could possibly want to
collapse yes in there and so one way of
viewing this is that each of these
universes takes up residence at some
coordinate in Hilbert space in Hilbert
space but Hilbert space is not space
it's just an abstract mathematical thing
so yeah when you talk about two
different branches of the wave function
you can't say well how nearby are they
rather they are perpendicular to each
other they're fully isolated from one
another even that is a little bit of
exaggeration they're very very very
isolated from each other very very very
not fully and even though we've tucked
the two branches into a mathematical
abstraction the lived experience of a
conscious system is going to be every
bit as rich or poor or whatever it is so
if we did have this person who had the
one in a thousand experience even though
their universe is very thin they're
going to go on to live everybody's
meeting full of a life with as much
complexity etc etc yeah that's exactly
the cool part of many worlds that's not
an objection to is just a feature that
is interesting that your life span has
been a constant story of the weight of
your
branch of the wavefunction getting
thinner and thinner less and less of the
whole shebang
is attributable to your branch of the
wavefunction but from your point of view
it looks the same you're yourself
getting smaller the world around you is
getting smaller it looks to you like the
world is staying the same when you were
born it was already minuscule compared
to how it had been a century ago or a
million years ago or whatever it is or
even one second ago yeah now it's
important distinction as you had already
pointed out that making a decision is
not splitting the universe it is right
simply this decoherence right so unless
the decision you make involves a
decoherence like objectively assigning
it to the app and the phone exactly as
long as you realize the causality goes
from quantum systems Tico hearing to you
then you'll get it right you making a
decision does not cause quantum systems
to decohere or anything like that I
could see some people drawn to a sliding
doors like view of the universe where
every single decision I could have
possibly made is manifested by some
version of me somewhere exactly and
therefore the totality of meze have
lived all possible existences that ain't
the case well it's mostly not the case
so again there's always a quantum
probability that weird things happen
right like you put a cup of coffee on
the table there's a probability in
conventional quantum mechanics that the
cup of coffee tunnels through the table
and falls to the floor it's incredibly
tiny in the ordinary Copenhagen way of
thinking and it's also incredibly tiny
in many worlds the difference is that
nevertheless in many worlds a tiny
fraction of the wavefunction the
universe has that happen okay and then
that place that had the coffee tunnel
through the table goes on to have
gazillions of offspring exactly filled
with gazillions of people who witnessed
that yes but gazillions is nothing I
know I'm created sizeof helper space but
there are also gazillions of universes
in which you made some really weird
decision okay but you didn't make it and
that caused the universe to branch
rather there's an extraordinarily
unlikely coincidence between various
atoms in your brain that caused various
neurons to fire that caused you to make
a certain decision so there are all
sorts of weird possibilities that are
happening out there in branches of the
universe including one
in which it looks like you made a
different decision but the causality
goes from the atoms in your brain to
your macroscopic self not the other way
around so in this interpretation there
can actually be many radically different
lived lives for losing any given person
even though any one of these quantum
decoherence --is is such a tiny and
seemingly insignificant you'd always
think of all these possibilities as
being as if they have real probabilities
of happening in a good old frequentist
interpretation so the unlikely ones you
should really think of as unlikely even
though they're there the other thing
that intrigues me about it is often
times when people talk about decoherence
they talk in terms of span and splitting
in two because that's an easy thing to
wrap your head around but if you're
pinning down an electrons location in
space that's arguably cloning the
universe an infinite number of times
right with the wave function puts the
electron at any one of countless
positions like if there's a smooth
gradation of positions even around an
atom collapsing that wave function could
create gazillions of universes correct
you can create a measurement apparatus
without infinite precision when we do
the detections when we do pin down the
location of an electron in the lab how
precise do we get hey you know medium
precise medium precise enough to make
thousands of universes or billions of
universe yeah I don't I don't know the
procedure no doubt okay but again yeah
there's plenty of room there are 10 to
the 88th photons in the observable
universe which is way more than there
are protons or neutrons like most of the
particles in the universe are either
photons or neutrinos and most of those
photons are just tootling along in the
universe they're not interacting in dqo
hearing right so they're not splitting
the universe but let's say that every
single one of them is putting the
universe a million times a second into
right to the 10 to the 88th every 1
millionth of a second plenty room for
that in Hilbert space in Hilbert space
yeah you know I'm not even coming close
to using up all of Hilbert space even if
that were as bad as it were no don't
worry about the atoms in your body
decaying are you making just oh I'm not
worried about any of it no I think on a
practical level this is not something
that impacts one's daily decisions well
Sean thank you so much
for having me here my pleasure rather is
a great conversation
[Music]
you
[Music]